il ya un an et demi
jacqueline a dû placer son père ancien
chez sylvie avec ses pertes de mémoire
et ses problèmes de langage il n'était
plus autonome jacqueline n'a pas le
choix elle doit mettre la maison
paternelle en vente aux nouvelles en
fouillant dans les papiers de son père
elle découvre un mandat d'inaptitude qui
la désignent comme mandataire elle
transcende et vous avec un notaire pour
tout régler mais première déception
le notaire lui explique que le mandat
d'inaptitude n'est valide que s'il est
homologué par le tribunal
elle devra donc déposé une requête à la
cour
le notaire lui dis qu'avec sa requête
elle devra déposer un rapport médical et
un rapport psychosocial sur des tas de
son père aux problèmes dit jacqueline
ces rapports existent déjà mais deuxième
déception comme ces documents remonte à
plus d'un an
le notaire informe que le tribunal pour
elle est rejetée
et pourquoi une telle exigence s'écrit
jacqueline parce que le tribunal
souhaite que les rapports représente
réalité du mmm a des tas de son père de
s'être améliorée ou avoir empiré en un
an et demi et pour la cour c'est aussi
une façon de protéger la personne qu'on
veut déclarer inapte le fin mot de
l'histoire
gérer un mandat d'inaptitude est déjà un
fardeau
évitez vous des maux de tête fait le
homologué au plus vite